ربما بدأت أشعر بالتوتر
خلال الـ 24 ساعة الأولى من ولادة ابني ،
لكن في النهاية ستنتشر
وتصبح أعظم بكثير عندما أصبح أبًا لأول مرة
لم يكن ما توقعه ديفيد ليفين
أنه قال إن طفله بكى كثيرًا
على مدار أسابيع.
بدأت تراودني بعض
الأفكار السلبية للغاية حول طفلي
وحول احتمال إيذائه ، كنت
عدوانيًا جدًا تجاهه
كأنك يمكن أن تكون عدوانيًا لفظيًا تجاه
طفل يبلغ من العمر أربعة أسابيع أو خمسة أسابيع حتى
كطبيب أطفال مخضرم يبلغ من العمر 16 عامًا
لم يكن ليفين يعلم أنه كان يعاني من
نوبات اكتئاب ما بعد الولادة من قبل الأب أو
أنه لم يسمع به من قبل ، لكنه يؤثر
على واحد من كل عشرة آباء ، كما يقول الدكتور توفا
والش الذي أمضى سنوات في البحث عن
ppd يظهر أن الآباء
يعانون أيضًا من تغيرات هرمونية حولها.
ولادة طفل ويمكن أن يكون ذلك
عاملاً إذا كان شريكك يكافح
وهذا عامل خطر مهم بشكل خاص
ولكن الاكتئاب أيضًا أكثر
شيوعًا  عند الآباء الأصغر سنًا
والآباء الذين يكافحون من
الناحية المالية أكثر ، ما هي الأعراض التي
يمكن أن تكون مختلفة لدى الآباء والتي لا
نراها عادةً في الأمهات يشعرن بمزيد من
الغضب والشعور بالغضب وأحيانًا
يلقيان بنفسك في العمل أو يمارسان
المزيد من الشرب أو تعاطي المخدرات
يقول والد بروكلين مو غرين إنه قام بفحص
كل صندوق تقريبًا بحثًا عن ppd وأصبح عاطلاً عن العمل
قبل ولادة طفله ، وكانت زوجته
تكافح من أجل الرضاعة الطبيعية ولديها
اكتئاب ما بعد الولادة ، وأنا أحاول
مساعدتها ولكن لا يمكنني فعل ذلك ، لذا بدأت الآن
أشعر بالعجز  لا قيمة له ويتصاعد
إلى ما يشبه الاكتئاب الخاص بي ،
يقول الأخضر إنه انسحب
وبدأ يشرب المزيد ،
كانت هناك نقطة عندما كنت أعطي
ابنتي حمامًا وكنت مثل الزومبي ،
لم أكن هناك مثل عقليًا ،
لم تكن هناك  نظرت إلي
والطريقة التي نظرت بها إلي أخبرتني بأنك لست
هنا أنت لست حاضرًا ، كانت
مكالمة الاستيقاظ التي يحتاجها الأخضر يقول إنه
وجد مجموعة دعم للآباء حيث
تعلم  حول ppd
، أعطته مكانًا لمعالجة مشاعره
عندما تشعر بالعجز ، فأنت
تعتقد فقط أنه أنت
وليس هو شيء سريري
يؤثر على جسدك ،
وعقلك ، وعواطفك ، ومن الصعب أن
يقول ديفيد ليفين إنه كافح للعثور على
مجموعة دعم ما بعد الولادة للرجال الذين اختاروا
بدلاً من ذلك رؤية معالج منتظم ،
ما اختبرته لم يكن فريدًا وهذا
ما أريد أن يعرفه الناس أن هذا
يحدث للآباء وبمساعدة يمكنك
التغلب عليه